[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour une émission à la
coloration
anticapitaliste assez marqué je reçois
en effet jeunes bien pour son livre le
consumérisme à travers les objets
renault farruco commissaire avec your
land râle de l'exposition libres comme
l'art qui se tient au siège du parti
communiste français jusqu'au 31 janvier
et nikolay à rossi du groupe iaross qui
sera nouvel album apnée et dont on
commence tout de suite pas les mêmes
images que vous avez choisie pour
illustrer notre époque la vôtre nicolas
c'est celle ci
alors c'est c'est des migrants en fait à
la frontière
biélorussie pologne et pourquoi j'ai
choisi cette image parce que c'est une
image qui me touchent déjà ça touche
beaucoup
elle est belle mais c'est une super
belle image et puis au delà de ça en
fait ça pour moi ça représente un petit
peu beaucoup même la barbarie un petit
peu de notre époque voilà le côté les le
fait qu'on érige des murs entre nous et
puis d'autant plus là c'est la
symbolique elle est assez forte ses murs
mais un mur de barbelés vers les
barbelés qui déchire les chairs il ya
tout et que ce sont des enfants qui sont
derrière et que ce sont des enfants qui
sont derrière voilà général quand on
veut toucher les européens il faut leur
montrer des enfants we dance et des
adultes ils sont moins sensibles oui
renault d'autres images à vous
alors moi c'est un tableau de bernard
rancillac qui est décédé hier donc
bernard rancillac ses initiateurs de la
figure de figuration narrative en france
sorte de pop art à la française
qui était avec hervé télémaque jacques
monory eduardo arroyo un des artistes
phares de de la france ses fans de
l'europe et ce tableau particulièrement
donc c'est les femmes d'alger c'est une
femme égorgée est-ce qu'on voit pas au
premier abord vous ne l'avez montré je
n'ai pas vu j'ai cru que tu es très sexy
au début on pense qu'elle dort moi je me
souviens d'avoir eu cette toile à
l'atelier chez chez bernard et j'avais
fait un rapprochement avec la mort de la
vierge du caravage et m'avait dit que la
prochaine fois il passera la
mitraillette sincères je n'avais pas
trop d'avoir trop de culture et donc bah
c'est une immense perte pour l'art
français il est mort à 81 dix ans et on
leur présente dans l'exposition avec
trois tableaux très très important on en
verra d'ailleurs fédéral elle avait pas
du che et un autre portrait en hommage à
cette série qui l'avait fait à l'époque
de des attentats du gia en 93 en algérie
et j'aime bien votre image à vous la
voici
alors c'est une photo prise sur une
plage de marseille début octobre
on voit donc que la plage est jonchée de
déchets en fait il y avait eu des
inondations peu avant et tous les
déchets des marseillais était partie à
la mer dans des conditions un peu
particulières parce que les éboueurs
étaient en grève étaient en grève
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une loi qui
s'appelle la loi de transformation de la
fonction publique qui veut les faire
travailler plus pour le même prix pour
le même salaire pardon
or leur salaire est déjà insuffisant
compte tenu du service public qui
rendent cette image elle me touche parce
que on voit que ben le on ne traite pas
les travailleurs des déchets à la
hauteur de leur métier étant donné tout
ce qu'on consomme on voit bien que ce
sont que des produits jetables sur sur
la mer des contenants jetables des
canettes des bouteilles etc et qui c'est
qui ramassent bas ce sont des bénévoles
donc en fait aujourd'hui on consomme
trop on produit trop et on n'est même
pas capable de donner aux travailleurs
des déchets à ceux qui ramassent tous
ces déchets la place qu'il mérite dans
notre société et le salaire qu'il mérite
et puis ben quand ils font grève eh bien
ils deviennent les boucs émissaires on
se plante d'eux dans les médias ont dit
à 100 les éboueurs en grève ça ne serait
pas arrivé et que qu'est ce qu'on en
voit on crée pas d'emplois on envoie des
bénévoles pour ramasser leurs déchets
donc voilà toutes les contradictions un
petit peu réuni sur cette photo toutes
les contradictions d'un système
économique qui surconsomment qui se
reproduit qui sur distribuer mais qui
n'est même pas capable de donner aux
éboueurs la place qu'il mérite dans ce
système elle me touche particulièrement
parce que moi je suis né de marchionne a
marseille j'ai grandi là bas et je
connaissais plage et c'est un ami de ma
famille qui me l'envoyer voilà et on va
parler bah tout de suite avec vous des
objets jetables parce que il y en a pas
mal
[Musique]
jeanne bien vous publiez donc le
consumérisme à travers ces objets aux
éditions indigène divergences vous avez
choisi un certain nombre d'objets comme
les gobelets les mouchoirs les
smartphones ou les déodorants pour nous
montrer comment le capitalisme
transforme tout en marchandise ainsi été
gratuit devient payant c'est ça c'est un
les aspects du capitalisme effectivement
de créer du marché là où il n'y en a pas
deux par exemple de valoriser le regard
de rendre de faire du regard une
marchandise en mettant des vitrines dans
l'espace public de transformer un bien
de première nécessité comme l'eau et
bien en marchandises en le servant dans
des gobelets qui sont payants de créer
de la peur de la honte du malaise de son
propre corps notamment chez les femmes
donc de leur vendre des odeurs
artificiel c'est effectivement un des
aspects du capitalisme que de tout un
marchand disait on va on va regarder les
objets les gobelets en détails parce que
c'est vraiment intéressant avant les
gobelets il y avait des tâches communes
dans les fontaines publiques aux états
unis tout le monde buvait à une taxe
commune on va voir une image qui est
dans votre livre voilà on le voit et
d'une petite tasse reliés par une
chaînette et tout le monde buvait ça
pouvait pas durer alors c'est déjà le
résultat d'un mouvement social en fait
cessé chaînette ses fontaines publiques
que ce soit aux états unis en angleterre
ou même en france il ya eu des
mouvements étaient des mouvements contre
l'alcoolisme qui défendent est la
possibilité d'avoir de l'eau gratuite
dans la rue donc ça c'est le milieu du
19e siècle et effectivement il n'y avait
pas d'eau courante il n'y avait pas de
l'eau comme ça dans la rue donc
effectivement on buvait d'autres
boissons que de l'eau et donc c'est des
mouvements de femmes qui ont revendiqué
la possibilité d'avoir de l'eau gratuite
effectivement il y avait des tasses
commune est donc bien la fin du 19e
siècle arrivant avec la découverte les
découverts de la microbiologie on s'est
rendu compte que c'est à ce véhicule et
des germes et il ya eu là aussi des
démobilisations de scientifiques
notamment pour faire disparaître les
taches commune mais il faut distinguer
les mobilisations des scientifiques pour
faire disparaître une tâche commune qui
est dangereuse démobilisation des
industriels pour remplacer le nas
commune par des gobelets payant et
jetable parce qu'il ya d'autres manières
que de boire le premier gobelets
jetables il a inventé en 1907 et
immédiatement le baptise que vous
racontez le gobelet sanitaires c'est à
dire que c'est il est là pour vous
sauver votre gobelet s'appelle la clim
cup donc le gobelet propre le global et
sans
pardon
mais tous les autres marques ont suivi
ont pris des noms et lorsque link up
anti bactériologique cup etc sera donc
ils ont tous surfé sur sept et c'était
ça ou la mort c'est ce que nous montre
bien ce que ce cette image effectivement
on se on se repasse aides et les
microbes le gobelet donc lé nous sauver
surtout pour la grippe espagnole 1 on
sait qu'elle a été elle a fait des
ravages aux états unis parler la grippe
espagnole évidemment le gobelet prend
tout son sens oui mais en toutes les
maladies sont passés dans les publicités
pour les gobelets jetables la grippe la
grippe espagnole
là on a une allégorie de la mort on sait
pas très bien cette mort auquel et cette
maladie
simplement parce que j'aimerais dire
c'est que effectivement oui partager
d'état sans contexte épidémique c'est
dangereux simplement il ya énormément
d'alternative pour boire de façon
sécurisée et c'est le gobelet qui l'a
emporté parce qu'ils ont su récupérer
cette mobilisation scientifique et
sociale à leur profit en reprenant cette
iconographie préventive n'est distribué
par l'état en payant un ce genre de
prospectus et en reprenant dans leurs
publicités dans leur nom de marque tout
cet imaginaire hygiéniste qui était à
l'époque très forte puisque c'était une
vraie victoire que de découvrir ce
qu'était un microbe comment se propage
et les imiter me etc et alors ça va
accompagner enfin le gobelet un lot
gobelets jetables qui va devenir
rentable au fur et à mesure il
accompagne le développement de la
restauration rapide qui aux états unis
est fondamentale puisque ce que les
américains mangent c'est assez mauvais
donc il faut le manger le plus
rapidement possible le marché seul aussi
pour pas perdre de temps donc la
restauration rapide se développe vous
notez d'ailleurs que rake rock le fameux
celui qui va rendre mcdonald's célèbre
dans le monde entier avait d'abord été
un représentant gobelets jetables c'est
vrai alors si le l'emballage je tape ce
se développe avec la restauration rapide
s'est pas de temps parce que ce qu'ils
mangent ce qu'ils mangeaient mauvais et
qu'il faut les manger le gîte moi ce que
je sais c'est parce que en fait il ya un
argumentaire
managériales économique derrière en fait
l'argumentaire à s'adresser plutôt aux
patrons de restaurants pour leur dire si
vous mettez des emballages jetables vous
avez besoin de moins de ressources
humaines vous avez pas besoin de gens
pour faire la plonge les gens pour faire
le service de gens pour s'occuper de
tous ces objets en fait le service ça va
être juste de l'encaissement mais tout
dans une boîte on vous la donne et au
revoir donc en fait l'argument il se
dirigeait vers les patrons de
restaurants en leur disant vous allez
dépenser moins et vous allez faire plus
de profits et ça va rires envahir aussi
les grands magasins ça va envahir les
stades les bureaux de les entreprises
les parcs tout le monde va se mettre aux
gobelets jetables et même ça va envahir
l'espace privé c'est à dire qu'une fois
qu'on a conquis tous ces espaces publics
où effectivement il peut y avoir un
argumentaire du type attention il ya des
gens qui passent toute la journée on
sait jamais on peut être malade c'est
pas pratique on n'a pas toujours ses
affaires avec soin ça c'est l
argumentaire pour l'espace public et
puis finalement ça va même envahir
l'espace privé avec des publicités cette
fois dirigé explicitement aux femmes
pour leur dire que une des manières de
résoudre tous leurs problèmes
domestiques
le service la cuisine le soin des
enfants les maladies eh bien il faut
mettre des gobelets dans toute la maison
les gobelets jetables et que donc c'est
plus facile que de s'occuper de sa
vaisselle de s'occuper des ses enfants
par différentes manières donc en fait
servi en veille tous les espaces mais ça
va nous ça va arriver dans les années 70
en europe c'est plutôt aujourd'hui j'ai
l'impression que ça dure encore je pars
dans l'espace privé domestique j'ai
l'impression que ça de cette dure encore
dans les l'occasion des anniversaires ou
des fêtes là on achète des gobelets
jetables pour les invités mais sinon ça
se fait plus oui c'est à la base c'est
un objet un peu exceptionnel c'est à
dire et il n'est pas censé servir au
quotidien mais en réalité ils ont essayé
en réalité on observe quand on interroge
les gens parce que j'ai aussi essayé de
fonctionner avec des méthodologies un
peu plus être nos graphiques et pas
seulement de l'histoire donc quand on
interroge les gens sur leurs pratiques
liées au jetable on se rend compte que
les gens pensent toujours que un gobelet
un mouchoir c'est pas grand chose en
fait c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel
ah oui là sur le moment j'ai pas pris
j'ai pas pensé j'ai pas prévu bon allez
gobelets jetables mais en fait cette
exception elle arrive presque tous les
jours aux gens parce que sur leur lieu
de travail ils vont à la cafétéria parce
qu'ils prennent les transports et qu'ils
ont besoin d'un café sur le chemin extra
donc en fait c'est un petit objet léger
qui coûte pas cher qui prend pas
beaucoup de place qu on oublie très vite
parce qu'on met dans une poubelle et que
la poubelle elle va être collectées mais
en réalité sur le long terme on en
utilise énormément et cet imaginaire la
de la légèreté de la petite chose de la
facilité avec laquelle les ordures sont
enlevés c'est aussi un imaginaire qui
vient de la publicité en réalité ces
objets là ils ont une réalité matérielle
une réalité très lourdes c'est du
plastique donc c'est du pétrole et même
le carton on ne peut pas bien le
recycler aujourd'hui donc c'est des
objets qu'on a un impact énorme et tout
et on en achète beaucoup beaucoup pesé
par milliards voilà ces petites
exceptions de temps en temps en réalité
non alors passons aux mouchoirs parce
que c'est ça aussi c'est intéressant
comment les les mouchoirs jetables ont
remplacé le mouchoir en tissu qui
servait à peu près à tous depuis le
moyen-âge c'était vraiment un objet vous
parlez d'objets total
oui parce qu'il y est il est dit servait
à la fois de vêtements de signes
d'outils aussi de d'hygiène nettoyage
etc donc c'était vraiment mais on
mettait des choses dedans dans son
mouchoir
ça qu'il va servir de pense bête il a pu
aussi servir d'outil de lecture à une
époque où les médias étaient beaucoup
moins développés donc c'était vraiment
un objet personnel qu'on pouvait garder
très longtemps voire toute sa vie au
célèbre des ses initiales sur son
mouchoir tâche est donc c'était un objet
très personnalisé est important il avait
une dimension aussi affectif très forte
et en fait pourquoi est ce qu'il a été
remplacé par des produits jetables là
aussi c'est une histoire industrielle en
fait il n'ya pas un jour un médecin
quelque part qui a dit voilà la solution
problème des épidémies c'est le mouchoir
jetable en tout cas ce qu'ont pris la
parole la thune n'ont pas été écoutés
par l'industrie l'industrie est venu
quant à lui un problème économique en
gros l'entreprise kleenex la marque
kleenex appartient aujourd'hui à
kimberly clark qui est une grande
entreprise américaine qui produisait du
papier et pendant la première guerre
mondiale ils ont produit des bandages et
les blessés oui voilà des bandages pour
les soldats blessés ou pour les civils
blessés et à la fin de la première
guerre mondiale il se retrouvait avec
les stocks de cette matière clés qu'ils
appellent eux c'est du coton et surtout
avec des stocks énormes savais pas quoi
faire donc c'est un problème industriel
que de rentabiliser ses stocks invendus
et donc c'est à partir de là qu'ils vont
créer
ces mouchoirs jetables et on voit dans
la publicité qui est derrière vous
kalaba ça n'a pas du tout été des
problèmes des produits qui ont été
vendus et promu comme des produits
d'hygiène pour se moucher ou soigner les
bébés c'était des produits de beauté en
fait c'était pour mettre et enlever de
la crème des surplus de crème dont wells
ça s'adresse clairement à des femmes de
classe supérieure à une époque où le
maquillage les cosmétiques ça reste un
très grand luxe donc c'était pas du tout
des produits destinés au peuple pour
qu'il aille mieux pour supprimer en même
temps vous dites que le mouchoir et est
devenu un marqueur social notamment en
france la partie 2014 le mouchoir c'est
vraiment quelque chose c'est
l'aristocratie ça sert aussi à ça sert
aussi à on le hall parfume parce que les
odeurs sont assez fétide personne ne se
lavent donc ça sert aussi à ça le
mouchoir le mouchoir jetable montferrand
tissu a commencé quand même comme un
accessoire des classes dominantes des
clubs des classe aristocratique et moi
je pense que quand kleenex commander des
produits jetables il reprend cet
imaginaire il réclamerait id4 des
actrices ils payent des grandes vedettes
américaines pour poser avec des kleenex
en se maquillant en reprenant cet
imaginaire de distinction sociale mais
cantine etc s'est rendu compte que les
gens ont observé que se servait de ses
produits pour se moucher ou pour essuyer
toutes sortes de sécrétions et bien il a
surfé sur cette vague là et il a changé
son positionnement son ciblage marketing
d'ailleurs que les premiers mouchoirs
jetables sont les japonais qui les ont
cités en papier de soie tout à fait
c'est les japonais quand les premiers
mais ça vaut pour beaucoup beaucoup de
produits jetables en papier cessé d idée
à la base japonaise d invention
japonaise
mais qui sont pas devenus des produits
internationaux et sont devenus des
produits internationaux quand ils ont
été en général repris refabriquer par
des grandes entreprises américaines ou
européennes
il y avait des gobelets jetables à
l'inauguration de votre exposition
notons qu'elle doit fabien que bhl et je
tape que la vodka au litre non non ce
que disait jeanne par rapport à le plus
à l'histoire de l'art sans évoquer un
tableau de poussin qui est conservée au
louvre c'est diogène qui n'a plus qu'une
et qu elle et qui voit quelqu'un encore
plus pauvre que lui qui boit avec la
main et prend sur lesquels il la jette
c'est un tableau sympa de poussins qui
au louvre et par rapport aux mouchoirs
c'est aussi un jeu pensé à antoine
doinel qui dit qu'ils se bougent jamais
dans du papier antoine doinel c'est le
héros de truffaut dont gmail en du
papier parce qu'il ya des vraies
histoires d'amour dont qui il a besoin
de tissus besoin d'écrire et ça me
faisait aussi pensé que c'était un objet
de drague nos mouchoirs oui on jette
onze jeunes hommes essayé a longtemps sa
hotte chatel son mouchoir continue de
jeter métier
mais c'est effectivement un objet de
draguer notamment dans les communautés
gay américaine il ya un code couleur qui
va avec mais ce ne sont pas des produits
jetables ça leur bande à regarder la
pilule c'est là est intéressante parce
que là c'est plus tardivement mais on
explique aux gens que un mouchoir en
tissu si on se mouche dedans et qu'on le
rouge dans sa poche en fait on emporte
avec soi les microbes ça ça va être
ensuite quand on va vouloir convaincre
les gens de se servir du kleenex pour se
moucher et plus de son mouchoir en tissu
tout à fait donc on ne revient pas
correct gobelet c'est que l'argumentaire
et les génisses tu c'est une stratégie
publicitaire d'abord on va positionner
produits comme un cosmétique on va
chatouiller l'envi de distinction des
classes dominantes et puis quand on voit
que ça marche pas vous dire ah ben si on
a si on inventait que c'était un outil
médical en fait est que ça permettait de
résoudre tous les problèmes sanitaires
des gens et donc c'est à partir des
années 40 30 40 que le kleenex est
devenu la solution à tous les problèmes
de santé de son bébé à tout puisque avec
l'idex on essuie tout
l'eia des kleenex à peu près d'eux pour
toutes les situations y compris à côté
du lit des prostituées oui alors il ya
une histoire sexuelle de là du kleenex
aussi delà de la publicité pour kleenex
utilisé sur la partie des années 70 ils
ont sorti un kleenex mam size donc
taillé l'iphone
avec je pense pour moi clairement une
suggestion de l'utilisation du kinect
dans la masturbation ou dans les
rapports sexuels évidemment c'était pas
explicite dans la publicité mais on a
des publicités très genre et la
destination des femmes qui sont censés
être excité par cet accessoire qui est
le kleenex
alors très genre est aussi basse et on
va voir c'est ce que c'est c'est le
déodorant là ça va être très genre le
déodorant ben là c'est ce qu'on parlait
de marqueur social c'est l'odeur de
transpiration qui au 19e siècle est un
marqueur social sorte la transpiration
les travailleurs alors on trouve des
textes là dessus on trouve des textes
encore une fois quand on est quand on
fait de l'histoire ça pue un peu sur des
sources on trouve des textes qui qui
associe
les odeurs à toutes sortes de problèmes
sociaux les femmes les prostituées
sentirais tout le temps ça vient de 0,2
du latin de la racine latine du mot paix
donc on trouve des textes qui associe
les étrangers les femmes les pauvres les
travailleurs à différentes odeurs on est
dans une grande époque d'anthropologie
raciale raciste classiste etc et on est
capable époque on rêve qu'on pourrait
décrire le physique des pauvres décrire
leurs odeurs etc donc il ya cette idée
que l'odeur de transpiration c'est
quelque chose de dévalorisant
socialement parce que c'est lié au
travail de même qu'à une époque les
aristocrates cultiver leur blancheur de
pau pour se distinguer des agriculteurs
qui prenaient le soleil dans les champs
donc tout aspect du corps peuvent être
transformés en mares casse sociale
ce qu'ont fait les grandes marques de
déodorants c'est de récupérer ses peurs
sociales dans leur communication parce
qu'elle est pourquoi parce qu'elle
vendait un produit qui n'était utilisée
par personne quand elles ont mis sur le
marché les déodorants donc ça on est là
aussi au tout début du 20e siècle aux
états unis personne en acheter les gens
étaient méfiants de ces produits
chimiques qu'on mettait sur la peau qui
décolorer les vêtements qui pouvait
hériter donc en fait elle n'avait pas de
succès et ça a commencé à avoir du
succès quand la publicité s'en est mêlé
quand les marques ont fait appel à des
grandes agences américaines qui ont en
gros commencé à structurer dans les
années 10 sur la madison avenue et c est
à partir de là et bien sonné ce qu'on
appelle les shame campagne c'est-à-dire
des campagnes de la honte des campagnes
adressé aux femmes d'abord on leur
explique que si elle n'utilise pas
certains cosmétiques et notamment les
déodorants et bien elles ne trouveront
jamais l'amour elles sont rejetées en
société elles seront seuls malheureuse
déprimé et c'est donc on a des campagnes
très agressive à destination des femmes
et à partir de là ça marche d'ailleurs
les publicités responsables de ce genre
de campagne sont félicités on leur donne
des prix de la publicité et tout le
monde comprend six les clics si la
publicité fait ventes du produit c'est
logique qu'on lirait congrès on pourrait
l on pourrait aussi se demander si la
publicité en tant que message sur
l'espace public ne devrait pas être
réglementé et pourrait l'interdire on
l'a fait dans un certain nombre de pays
d'ailleurs mais mais je veux dire à
partir de là on peut pas ils font leur
travail quoi wima tout travail peut être
réglementé un challenge tout ce travail
est soumis à un code du travail et
notamment les messages qui sont publiés
dans l'espace public peuvent être
agressifs peut être un descendant peut
pas dire tout et n'importe quoi surtout
quand on s'adresse comme ça à toute la
population indistinctement mettant des
affiches dans les rues donc ça a été
volé une époque de deux fois
ressuscitées drôle c'est que vous dites
de façon plus récente quand on se
rapproche de nous les femmes valeur
c'est là où je parlais de publicité
genre et ça va être plutôt les jeunes
sportives on va montrer des jeunes
sportives
athlétique
performante qui utilisaient des eaux
d'oran et je pense que quand j'étais
enfant c'était comme ça et les hommes en
revanche c'est des hommes qui ce qu'ils
s'envoient du d or dans comme ça et qui
après deviennent irrésistibles auprès
des femmes c'est le séducteur con qu'on
caresse dans le sens du poil si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
c'est la femme dynamique
autonome indépendante performante qui
est visé ça c'est une autre période donc
là on n'est plus dans les 72 80 où
effectivement on commence à moins
pouvoir avoir cette image de la femme
complètement passive qui cherche le mary
à tout prix et qui ne peut compter que
sur son corps et sur sa séduction donc
on mettra en scène des images de femmes
un peu plus actives dans des contextes
de travail dans des contextes de sport
donc des contacts d'activité socialement
légitimement au c'est vrai qu'après tout
le sport c'est valoriser c'est bien de
faire du sport au sport on transpire
donc on met en scène ces femmes
dans ces contextes la d'activité et mais
on leur dit toujours de mettre des
autres et inversement les hommes voilà
ça va être tout les campagnes donc
notamment les campagnes axe et lynx qui
sont adressés aux hommes en leur disant
que leur odeur de transpiration mélangé
à l'honneur de déodorant les rend
irrésistible et là on voit bien la
différence entre hommes et femmes c'est
à dire que les hommes ont droit de
sentir leur propre odeur et elle est
valorisé socialement un homme qui
transpire c'est un homme actif un homme
un vrai un homme séduisant donc il l'a
aimée du déodorant mais peut garder un
peu son odeur à lui tandis qu'une femme
elle doit être aseptisé elle doit être
toujours très propre très fraîche comme
on dit ça c'est aussi un héritage de la
publicité du déodorant que de dire que
frêche et jolie c'est un petit peu
synonyme donc voilà j'ai vraiment un
traitement différencié des genres est
évidemment c'est au détriment des femmes
dont on attend des prouesses esthétiques
en général absolument inatteignable il
nous reste trois minutes avant la pause
un mot sur les smartphones il dit bien
que le smartphone est au 21e siècle ce
que la voiture était au xxème siècle
intelligent et sauf qu'il s'est
développé de façon beaucoup plus rapide
alors résumé nous comment on a fait du
smartphone le certainement l'objet le
plus répandu dans le monde jamais un
produit mais aussi bien marché à part
peut-être facebook qu'ensuite qui a
dépassé le smartphone mais c'est c'est
une ascension extrêmement rapide c'est
une diffusion extrêmement rapide en
même pas vingt ans d'un objet pourquoi
est ce qu'il est aussi aussi omniprésent
mais tout simplement parce qu'il est
extrêmement produits c'est un objet que
les produits dans des quantités
absolument faramineuses dans des
conditions absolument désastreuse
et donc à bas coûts pourquoi est-ce
qu'on peut s'acheter autant smartphone
si souvent parce que tout simplement ça
coûte pas si cher parce qu'il ya des
marques low cost et parce qu'elles
produisent tous les six mois tous les
ans de nouveaux modèles et pourquoi elle
sait si peu cher alors que ce sont des
produits précieux avec des matières et
une complexité quand même énorme mais
tout simplement parce que c'est pas
brillé par des esclaves des quasi
esclaves
on sait très bien qu'elle ait parmi les
les ouïghours qui sont réduits en
esclavage votre travail forcé en chine
il ya des fabricants d'électronique on
sait très bien que ceux qui ne sont pas
des esclaves qui sont embauchés dans des
grandes sous-traitants comme foxconn en
chine ils sont ils sont sous payés et
parents qui font énormément d'heures
supplémentaires donc il ya cette réalité
là en fait derrière derrière ces objets
là mais qu'est ce qui fait qu'on ne peut
plus on n'a pas ne pouvait plus se
passer de et la foi de téléphones sans
fil et
aussi d'un ordinateur dans la poche
alors la séance passerait plutôt du
point de vue d'un le consommateur donc
prenons enfin quand on dit nous quand on
dit en bon on va dire pour un
consommateur français moyen aujourd'hui
mettons de ce point de vue là bas tout
simplement parce qu'un objet c il est
pris dans des actions un objet il est
pris dans un contexte social dans lequel
il est utile inutile nécessaire superflu
et c est que le bain un mini ordinateur
aujourd'hui ça permet de travailler et
de et de communiquer et de vivre avec
les autres et plus vous aurez de service
qui se numérise aujourd'hui même tous
les services administratifs se numérise
plus vous rendrai cet objet nécessaire
si on peut même plus consultés je sais
pas moi ces impôts saqqaf son compte en
banque sans avoir tous me semble qu'on
pourrait le faire sur son ordinateur moi
ce qui me fascine j'ai vécu avant les
téléphones portables je sais qu'on
pouvait très bien vivre sans avoir un
téléphone portable que certes on allait
à la cabine téléphonique mais c'était
pas l'enfant d'aller dans une cabine
téléphonique
certes on pouvait pas nous appeler dans
la journée mais c'était pas la mort non
plus et quand on partait en voyage on
avait la paix aujourd'hui je peux plus
sortir sur mon portable bon c'est donc
quelque chose qui a changé en moi il ya
une organisation sociale dans laquelle
vous êtes inclus et qui vous vous oblige
à être sans cesse disponible pour un
certain nombre de doper rations qui sont
numérisées et donc on aura beau appeler
les gens à individuellement mieux
consommer ça n'aura pas de sens parce
que c'est un problème social c'est un
problème de comment notre société
organisée qu'est ce qu'on produit qu'est
ce qu'on distribue qu'est-ce qu'on veut
bien vendre et qu'est-ce qu'on est
qu'est-ce qu'on affiche comme le truc le
plus désirable en ce moment mais on
dirait que vous pourrez peut-être
quelqu'un avec un boulier et comme
diogène vous jetterez votre portable
le consumérisme à travers ces objets
c'est paru aux éditions divergences et
signé jane bien on fait une pause on
revient juste après
[Musique]
bono fort où vous êtes co commissaire
avec yolande râle de l'exposition libres
comme l'art qui se tient au siège du
parti communiste français place du
colonel fabien à paris jusqu'au 31
janvier qu'est ce qu'on y voit
exactement eh ben on s'y voit soi même
on s'y découvre en fait c'est une
exposition qui démarre donc dans les
années 20 pour aller jusqu'à aujourd'hui
quand je dis qu'on s'y découvre c'est
que par exemple dans une oeuvre qui fait
partie du fond de la fédération de
partis communistes de paris de picasso
qui est une plaque de cuivre qui
représente une sorte de caricature un
portrait de marcel cachin le fondateur
dont du parti communiste en 1920 encore
et toujours cette plaque de cuivre on se
reflète de dents et le jeu de reflets
continue un peu dans l'accrochage qu'on
a fait avec eric maurin scénographe ou
dans le bâtiment en fait c est ce qu un
des chefs-d'oeuvre de cette exposition
c'est le bâtiment du colonel fabien voit
d'ailleurs là bas qu est ce que vous
avez apporté la baguette de l'exposition
et vous l amorce toute une série de
miroirs en fait donc on a une sorte de
des faits un peu de dame de shanghai qui
fait qu'il ya des perspectives les
transversales qui secrètent partout et
qu'on s'y découvre ce soit même
militant ou non et surtout justement n'a
pas voulu faire avec yolande râle sur le
panégyrique du parti communiste mais au
contraire raconter toute une histoire de
l'art depuis les années 20 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à bâtir des tableaux qui
sont la peur la propriété du parti
communiste mais aussi de tableaux prêtés
dont vous êtes allés chercher les
peintres membres du pc les compagnons de
route on a travaillé en fait avec
yolande à base de en fait c'est pour
raconter toute l'histoire c'est le
philosophe bernard vasseur qui nous a
demandé à yolande et à moi de travailler
sur le fond des oeuvres qui
appartiennent au parti communiste
français à la fédération du pc de paris
dans ce fonds d'oeuvres donc on a trié
comme on a fait notre travail
d'archivage l'historien d'art pour
trouver un sens à toutes ces oeuvres
dont on a eu donc ce qu'on a appelé nos
trésors données dont qui ont été des
oeuvres qui ont été offertes pour je
sais pas la lutte contre l'apartheid
pour nelson mandela pour la guerre
d'algérie pour 20 plusieurs éléments des
fêtes de l'humanité où ainsi de suite
donc on avait une sorte de d'un tiers
d'oeuvre qu'on a géré qui sont nôtres
est ordonnée qui ont été notre notre
colonne vertébrale
par exemple j'avais un petit dessin de
marfin un abstrait français des années
60 c'est l'occasion de mettre un
chef-d'oeuvre de marfin c'est à dire que
en fonction des oeuvres qu'on avait on
les a conjugué avec des chefs-d'oeuvre
et en même temps cette problématique on
a voulu mettre en avant au tour de
réalisme et abstraction pour traiter
vraiment tout le siècle on va regarder
un certain nombre qui sont dans cette
exposition
fernand léger par exemple il ya un
fernand léger bien traités en verlan
léger alors ce qui est intéressant sur
fernand léger bon et ça c'est une pièce
donc c'est la fameuse tapisserie donc de
fernand léger donc du son autour du
poème de paul eluard liberté donc c'est
une pièce qui fait partie de la
fédération de paris qui a exposé au
parti communiste tout le temps bon alors
l'histoire de la pièce c'est un an après
la mort de paul eluard
seghers l'éditeur demande à fernand
léger de rendre hommage à son camarade
et donc il va faire un tiré à part une
sorte de dépliants sur reprenant liberté
alors bien sûr bon pour le grand public
le parc le l'artiste le plus célèbre du
parti communiste et fernand léger et
fernand léger ou pablo picasso pour
celle qui associe après la guerre voilà
bah picasso chagall est allé dans les
gels revient de new york et adhère au
parti communiste à partir de 45 cas
d'après le rapport avec fernand léger
parti communiste et toute une longue
histoire mais il ya des anecdotes que je
rappelle dans le catalogue ou par
exemple ils avaient exposé aux usines
renault et donc ils étaient très
contents d'exposer ses oeuvres en usine
et mais les travailleurs le regarder il
lui disait mais fernand tes personnages
avec leurs gros droit il pourrait pas
travailler
c'est ça nous le réalisme socialiste que
prenait le parti communiste soviétique
heroes heroes il plus âgés héros mais là
aussi c'est une oeuvre assez explicite
alors héros donc là lui sait on avance
donc toujours vivant et aux gens vivant
grands peintres de la figuration
narrative et ça c'est un tableau est
assez exceptionnel qu'on a eues par un
prêt particulier
donc c'est une oeuvre en fait qui est la
vue des américains par les russes
souriez tout est écrit en cyrillique
rona en fait là il la toile est coupée
mais en haut vous avez christophe colomb
qui débarque en amérique les indiens
vous avez kissinger ici peut cacher un
personnage du ku klux klan qui ont valu
l'angola vous êtes une critique de
hollywood où justement vous avez encore
les personnages du ku klux klan qui se
balade vous avez aussi les droits
civiques avec les noirs qui sont
envoyées nixon qui jouent au ping pong
avec mao au moment de la triangulation 1
n'a fait vous avez enfin donc c'est
toute une histoire de la conquête de
l'amérique vu par hérault mais avec ce
fantasme que la toile aurait été vu par
les russes et le groupe d'initiales or
lui je connaissais pas ce groupe il ya
une oeuvre de 1972 alors ça sur les
tortures une pièce exceptionnelle le
groupe dénonce ya en fait a été composé
de gros lot le parc dont vous avez une
toile julio le parc est plus connu pour
ses oeuvres cinétique pour le parti et
il s'est allié avec trois autres
camarades
josé gamarra
gamarra gamarra et netto et ensemble ils
ont décidé de faire une série de sept
tableaux contre la torture en amérique
latine nul ne sera jamais soumis à la
torture et nous nous ne montrons qu'une
des pièces 17 pièces qu assez
exceptionnel et qui est exposé en face
d'un tableau de roger somville qui a
encore une grande découverte il ya d un
peu comme édouard pignon un des grands
parcs du parti communiste belge et c'est
un immense tableau qui fait penser à
bien sûr un peu à picasso et qui
s'appelle le cri grecque qui renvoie à
la la au colonel en
cette époque là à peu près tous les
états d'amérique latine sont des
dictatures soutenues par les américains
est donc évidemment le parti communiste
soutient les opposants mais puis julio
le parc c1 c'est très intéressant de par
rapport à par exemple il faut pas
oublier tout
l'intérêt d'une iconographie
justement socialiste ou real socialistes
d'amérique latine avec les depuis les
muralistes depuis diego rivera orosco
donc à une vraie culture aussi en
amérique latine qu'on a un peu tendance
un peu à oublier avec le réalisme
socialiste plus soviétique voir ou
chinois il ya un portrait de mao alors
je sais pas qui l'a fait d'ailleurs ce
portrait et comment est il atterrit au
parti communiste alors c'est qui est
plutôt fâché avec mao de plus quasiment
1960 pour partie que vous avez de la
salle de la délégation étrangère où tout
le monde est venu arafat nelson mandela
sauf mao et donc ça c'est un petit coup
de main aux commissaires yolande râle
qui a voulu faire un clin d'oeil en
ramenant le portrait de mao mais c'est
un portrait de mao tsé première fois
qu'un portrait de mao
d'un portrait de mao qui est fait par
yan pei ming qui est un des grands
artistes chinois qui est en france
depuis maintenant les années 90 qui est
professeur aux beaux-arts de dijon qui
vient d'avoir une grande exposition à la
fondation lambert à avignon et c'est un
des grands artistes actuels il a fait
tout un travail aussi récemment sur
courbet et il avait fait toute une série
de portraits sur mao et aussi sur son
père et donc c'est des portraits aussi
assez critique finalement
de demain édouard pignon ami de picasso
lui aussi comme picasso contre le
réalisme socialiste une avaient été
mineures il a été ouvrier chez renault
chez citroën qu'est ce que représente ce
tableau est ce qu'on le salon bien sûr
c'est un tableau qui s'appelle l'ouvrier
mort c'est un tableau manifeste c'est un
tableau qui datent de 1936 c'est un
tableau qui renvoie aux grèves de 1936
qui renvoie aussi à l'univers du nord
parce que pignon il venait donc de
noeux-les-mines donc à l'univers des
mines peut penser au coup de grisou si
vous regardez sur li na au nom de
pignons et on y parle du tableau il ya
un ouvrier des mines qui parle et qui
pleure devant le tableau qui explique
quand il a vu ce tableau il a peur il a
pensé aux copains qu'il avait perdu
alors c'est un tableau très important
parce que c'est à l'époque où justement
on replonge dans le réalisme tout en
gardant les acquis du cubisme du
fauvisme donc si vous voulez 200 rejet
véritablement d avant-garde qui
rempliront lieu avant alors c'est un
tableau d'autant plus intéressant vous
avez une sorte de cadre dans le cadre
aussi bien une composition quand même
assez extraordinaire on a tous ces jeux
de lumière et se découpe de personnages
qui ferait penser un peu à jacques
villon le le frère de marcel duchamp et
on a surtout au premier rang donc ce
personnage le poing tendu cet ouvrier
mort qui fait bien sûr penser à une
déposition donc ce qui est très
intéressant du christ one by en a pas
d'autres qui ont été des femmes élues et
mes bras pour les positions de enfin
mais cette année là qu'on dit ismo
courbatures mais pour ceux qui luttent
c'est vrai mais bon tant pis ce que je
veux dire là dedans c'est que ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que quand vous
regardez le réalisme socialiste à la
française que ce soit ici pignon ou
taslitzky dont on présente la mort de
daniel casanova n'est grande martyrs
communiste mort en camp en fait vous
avez toujours un retour de
l'iconographie chrétienne et donc c'est
très intéressant de voir le lien entre
l'iconographie chrétienne retourner
autour du livre
gratuit on conduira à bas les
communistes pour simplifier c'est très
lisible aussi par exemple dans le
travail qu'on a fait avec yolande râle
sur les lettres françaises quand vous
voyez aragon on a toujours on a une
sorte image manichéenne du parti
communiste autour d'eux des ouvriers
mais ça a été très intéressant de voir
le lien avec la culture et
particulièrement avec la culture
chrétienne où vous trouvez je sais pas
des sujets sur les lie les églises
romanes de saint savin on va regarder là
il ya un dessin en 1937 alors je pense
que vous ne cessez pas qui en est
l'auteur mais qui a l'air de représenter
1 alors ça c'est un petit chef-d'oeuvre
de pierre tall cohade en s'intéressant
combes étiez le lien avec avec pignon
parce que finalement pignon et alcoa tu
or ils n'ont pas fait les beaux-arts cd
autodidacte alors autant pignon vient du
nord de la france autour de talent qu at
il s'appelait pierre jacob qui va
changer de nom pour pas être comme mieux
max jacob va donc sa perte alcoa tu qui
veut dire tête durant breton et tel quoi
tu as une première période axée autour
d'un mouvement qui s'appelle forces
nouvelles quelque chose qu'on a un peu
oublié dans l'histoire de l'art mais il
est très lié avec alberto giacometti et
avec francis grubert et c'est ce petit
dessin cette encre vient d'un prêt d'une
galerie de la galerie et war s rue de
seine à paris et et on le met en rapport
avec un immense tableau qui s'appelle le
grand massacre qui rend l'eau m'a enfin
en relation avec guernica un tableau
qu'elle conservait à au centre pompidou
et est donc toute cette série de deux
petits-enfants sont assez
exceptionnelles elle renvoie une
sculpture qui est devant elle de rené
iché rené iché c'est un des grands
sculpteurs aussi qui faisait partie de
forces nouvelles et qui est notre
culture qui s'appelle guernica et qui
est des fidji d'une petite fille à la
tête de mort et que rené iché a fait le
jour même où il a entendu le
bombardement de guernica à la radio est
devenu emblème sa fille lui demande mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe il l'a fait poser
pendant trois heures et il transforme
cette petite danseuse en martyr
il ya un tableau de bernard rancillac
aussi donc il nous expliquait pour un
champion votre réveil qui nous a quittés
hier
qu'est ce qui représente celui là alors
c'est un tableau qui en fait
contemporain de celui que j'ai montré
pour rendre hommage à bernard rancillac
c'est un tableau qui renvoie encore à
aux événements fin à la guerre à la
guerre civile de 93 en algérie et donc à
la montée du gia et à la montée de
l'islamisme
alors c'est des pièces très importante
moi j'ai une petite légende parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec bernard au
ciac pareil que yolande râle qui avait
organisé sa rétrospective à l'espace
niemeyer en 2017 et quand berlin avait
fait cette série tableau il avait
travaillé à base de vidéo clandestine
qui était sorti d'algérie et qui où les
femmes parler des tortures des viols des
gens qu'on a abandonné et donc il a fait
toute une série de femmes d'alger qui
renvoie bien sûr dans l'histoire de
l'art aux femmes d'alger de delacroix me
reprise par picasso mais les femmes
d'alger d'euros sillac eh ben ils ont
été torturés elles ont vécu les viols
elles ont vécu l'horreur de la guerre et
et c'est une série d'oeuvres
exceptionnelles et à l'époque on s'était
pas tues moi j'avais fait un article
dans l'événement du jeudi pour expliquer
que encore une fois bernard rancillac
été censuré dans le sens où personne n'a
voulu montrer ses tableaux de toutes les
institutions sont venus tout le monde a
trouvé ça formidable les personnes aient
le courage de les montrer eduardo arroyo
ne s'éteint pas très espagnole qui a fui
loin monisme c'est les derniers
l'éternel exilés
avec une ombre dans la main et une rose
au dessus mais ce lundi balancer un
diptyque on va voir l'autre on va voir
là en fait ces francos c'est franco qui
a l'air bien gentil avec sa première
colonne qu'il caresse et dans le tableau
d'après lui leur hache la tête ouais
c'est un tableau fondamentale d'eduardo
arroyo à l'époque où il pense à elle a
25 ans il fait une exposition qui
s'appelle abattoirs avec d'autres
artistes dont mark brusse dont on
présente beaucoup de sculptures et le
scandale né sait que et arroyo peint
toute une série de dictateur franco
salazar je sais plus tout est énorme et
des drapeaux nationaux derrière donc ils
sont tous bien nommé ça fait un scandale
avec de gaulle ont censuré l'exposition
on cache les drapeaux
c'est le succès d'arroyo succès deux
jours de scandale et ses tableaux sont
exceptionnelles dans le sens où il
renvoie on pense bien sûr à bécane mais
on pense aussi bien sûr à goya et donc
c'est vraiment un diptyque
extraordinaire très peu montré qui a
toujours été gardés chez son galeriste
historique qui s'appelait georges de thé
et donc est l'oeuvre c'est vraiment ses
deux premiers tableaux et on finit avec
une toile de eduardo arroyo qui présente
un en portrait de fernand léger qui est
son dernier tableau en grenat du début à
la fin entre autres l'exposition libres
comme l'art se tient jusqu'au 31 janvier
au siège du parti communiste c'est
l'occasion d'y entrer c'est surtout
l'occasion d'aller voir l' architecture
d'oscar niemeyer voilà et c'est une
exposition que je dirais quand même à
caractère assez exceptionnel vu les
prêts qu'on a pu avoir par des
institutions très importantes comme le
centre pompidou le musée matisse du
cateau-cambrésis des prêts de
collections privées puis il ya plus de
130 tableaux 200 documents on va faire
aussi beaucoup de conférences on va
commencer par yale livre il ya le
catalogue de catalogue que les une
grosse chronologie dans le catalogue
très importante des événements
politiques et culturelles de 1920 à
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
larousse c'est le nom du groupe le vôtre
c'est nicolas yaro si vous êtes chanteur
et violence et mist vous sortez un
nouvel album baptisé apnée vous avez
entièrement écrit et composé pourquoi
apnée
apnée en fait parce que l'apnée c'est
quelque part une retient sa respiration
volontairement et on va dans les
profondeurs et j'aimais bien cette idée
en fait deux
quelque part de je faisais je fais un
petit parallèle avec la pine et non
volontaire d'aujourd'hui voilà moi
c'était un petit peu cette idée là en
fait qu'on est aujourd'hui en apnée mais
non non volontaire on regarde tout c'est
un extrait du clip de barbarie donc un
des morceaux qui figurent dans ce nouvel
album
[Musique]
puisque le monde va s'y dans un carré
d'ortie puisque les bois oublier sont
des rêves transit puisque le temps des
amants chante encore dans le vent
puisque le chant des enfants s'est
couché au présent puisque le coeur et
crever comme un ballon de silence
puisque la peur est caché sous la peau
digne or puisque le corps est marqué au
fer blanc de l'oubli parce que ta peau
et blessés comme un soleil
radieux soleil
comme un soleil endormi
comme un soleil bien dormi
soleil
parce que les mots de tammo touches sont
réduits en poussière puisque la mer et
transit sur un lit de lumière ce que le
sol se dérobe sur les pieds de l'an viii
puis que le sens ici aux médias
compagnie puisque tu es points vont
fuser que des lance pierres parce que
dans les a souvent réduits en poussière
ce qu'il te reste à crier derrière
les meurtrières
[Musique]
sur des chars de lumière
your door de lumière
sur des chars lumière
[Musique]
ce qui m'a intéressé c'est en voyant ce
clip c'est qu'aujourd'hui on appréhende
la belgique très souvent par l'image et
pas par le son au fond et que le clip
raconte une histoire qui est pas
forcément dans la chanson oui c'est une
p dg a besoin que le réalisateur je sais
à qui le réalisateur de 10 0 voilà et je
suis il a peut-être raconter une
histoire qui lui passer par la tête en
écoutant cette chanson alors qu'il n'est
pas dans la chanson bien sûr bien sûr en
même temps il ya le sujet le sujet
principal de la chanson quelque part en
fait elle a choisi ce biais là de ce
sujet l'un pour évoquer quand même
l'idée principale de la chanson idée un
peu général oki parce que cette chanson
elle parle quand même de la différence
et du fait qu'on est tous voilà dans
cette société un petit peu comment dire
enfin que la différence dans cette
société est un problème souvent et elle
a choisi ce biais là et moi je trouve ça
assez intéressant et assez poétique lui
l'ouverture est ce que parce qu'en fait
il ya ce côté
comment dire c'est une drag queen en
plus donc finalement c'est le un sujet
qui outre ans femmes on peut dire ça
mais du coup c'est un sujet qui est
actuel mais qui est abordé par un sujet
qui est date des années 90 80 voilà donc
vous êtes montpelliérain nikola ya aussi
le groupe et montpelliérains comme comme
juillet gréco et mathias malzieu du
groupe dionysos le cas des affluences de
montpellier sur votre musique à la mer
c'est tout la mairie de faire un et non
non non c'est banal je dirais que
montpellier si vous voyez c'est ma ville
de coeur mais après je sais pas si je
peux parler de la ville en soi parce que
c'est moi c'est pas forcément la ville
qui m'attire mais j'aime cette ville
j'aime le mouvement la culture les
jeunes c'est une ville très dynamique
mais je dirais que ce qui en tout cas
par rapport à cet album ce qui m'a ce
qui m'a rapproché beaucoup de du chu de
montpellier c'est la méditerranée
puisque j'ai beaucoup été au bord de la
mer j'ai beaucoup j'adore ça la
contemplation le côté
nature on va écouter portant mais là ya
pas de clip que l'on veuille fabriquer
nous mêmes on peut voter
c'est comme si je marchais sur un fil et
sans repères sur un fil et sans repères
c'est comme si je me voyais ce défilé
dans les airs sous défilé dans les airs
c'est comme si je me sentais comme un
fils est pris dans le filet comme un
fils est prêt dans le film
c'est comme si je dansais sur un fil et
dans les airs sur un fil et dans les
airs dans les airs
en temps de bois pourtant de faire trois
petits tours et en arrière l'antre de
bois pin de fer entreprises touré en
arrière quand on de bois pourtant de
faire trois petits tours et en arrière
pantin de bois pourtant de faire trois
petits tours et axel
[Musique]
c'est pas très optimiste
je dirais qu'on est à l'image de ce
qu'ont de ce qu'on ressent dans la
société d'aujourd'hui en fait on n'est
que des des reflets mais j'espère que
pour ça j'espère pour vous vous croyez
encore aux lendemains qui chantent ou
même pas justement une chanson
d'ailleurs d'un album qui s'appelle
demain est en fait souvent on me dit ça
les paroles sont noirs timmins est en
fait
il ya quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
enfin que j'aime beaucoup et qui
s'appelle mano solo qui est mort et
qu'il y avait quand même des paroles
très noir très dark on peut même parler
de ferrer aussi et souvent moi ça me ça
ne me choque pas le désespoir au
contraire ces quelques parler de la
noirceur parler des choses qui sont la
présence d'un petit peu comme le
consumérisme quelque part c'est des
choses qui permet d'avoir de l'espoir
pour l'avenir et dans cette chanson là
par exemple demain c'est une chanson ou
qui parle clairement de ça en fait qui
parle et puis il ya demain qu'est-ce
qu'on fait demain demain c'est
maintenant demain c'est les actes qu'on
va passer vous croyez aux lendemains qui
chantent mais vous croyez surtout aux
cris des fourmis c'était le titre de
votre album précédent j'aimerais qu'on
écoute un extrait d'un clip la chanson a
été tirée de cet album précédent ses
chiens de garde
et là
[Musique]
des silences ahmar dans la mer de
silence
[Musique]
déshérence enfin histoire sans refrain
des caresses souffrent des corps en état
des sourires figés des mouvements
bétonnée
[Musique]
des machines à broyer
des soldes a cartonné
des horreurs à pleurer
des printemps s'en était
sans sutra peut-être on aura tout peut
être
[Musique]
on s'en foutra peut-être en enverra tout
peut être
[Musique]
des images à brider des reflets
reflet
des ravages effréné des rois
des armures à briser l'écart est
effritée
proclamée des armées
qui
voix script on se dit bon je peux vous
ranger dans dans la veine anti
capitaliste qui caractérise cette
émission c'est quand même assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir qu'on
proteste en france en tout cas le
contenu le capitalisme de façon assez
virulente et lettres depuis plus d'un
siècle
maintenant et qui a jamais eu de
champion du capitalisme en france il ya
discours anticapitaliste porté par la
plus beaucoup d'intellectuels
d'écrivains d'artistes au talent il n'y
a pas de champion du capitalisme
pression je parlais pas jeanne mas 2 par
rapport à son livre ça me faisait penser
à roland barthes et la mythologie elle
réagissait en disant que c'était pas du
tout le même principe et elle vous
dirais même que bart lui même a été
récupéré par les publicités
il a travaillé pour les féliciter ces
fameuses
l'étude choc biologiques d'une publicité
pour les pâtes panzani
l'impression que aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup moins de contestations en tout
cas au niveau des intellectuels de
manière de visu
moi j ai l intellectuel parce que j'aime
beaucoup ça va être des god oh mais
c'est l'été dans cette émission mais la
dernière parle de lui parce que j'aime
beaucoup mais moi je trouve plutôt qu'il
ya une chape de plomb un peu c'est un
peu c'est un peu mon impression
aujourd'hui on conteste le moine
capitalisme aujourd'hui contre la paix
contestée hier que dans wii voilà que
dans les années mais on en fait toujours
pas l'éloge moi ce qui m'étonne c'est
que personne n'en fait jamais les lol je
n'y a pas de grands romanciers qui ont
exalté le capitalisme il n'y a pas de
film à la gloire du capitalisme en
france il y en a eus aux états unis par
exemple mais pas en france vous trouvez
pas j'aime bien moi je pense que à
travers toute l'histoire du capitalisme
mais c'est plus d'un siècle dont on
parle il ya toujours eu ses défenseurs
et ses critiques c'est une histoire
aussi ancienne que l'industrie quand on
a commencé à
monter des usines bombay à mettre à
automatiser les outils de production les
ouvriers ont cassé les machines
il ya toujours eu des mouvements sociaux
après c'est des mouvements sociaux qui
laisse plus ou moins de traces on parle
souvent des intellectuels parce que les
intellectuels leur métier c'est de
laisser des traces d'écrire sur des
films de la musique autre chose
ça laisse plus de traces que les
mouvements sociaux à moins que ceux-ci
étaient repris dans les médias mais en
réalité dès le début nous sommes lucides
travail ya eu une critique et al'inverse
il ya eu des gens pour répondre aux
critiques et pour ce faire les pas en
bons de l'industrialisation et parangon
de la capitalisation et serra et il faut
toujours des économistes des patrons
mais est ce qu'il ya des pâtures les
autres du capitalisme dans la peinture
c'est andy warhol
mais qu'ils devaient faire brasser ça
pour une dénonciation oui enfin quand
justement il est il et il fait des mao
en papier peint rangers produite qu'on
se renseigne ac dit que c'est de la
récupération politique oui donc après
dans l'art c'est compliqué vu qu'on est
dans un système marchand aussi et que
les artistes qu'on montre justement
quand on peut reparler de rancillac là
je vois vous pourrez parler de gilles
aillaud on pourrait parler de tous ces
artistes qui ont fait des années 70 se
sont mis contre les institutions contre
les galeries ce que se créent en
collectif voulait vraiment évolué de
manière indépendante en tant qu'artiste
mais ont été finalement
récupéré par les institutions par le
marchand par les marchés et c'est très
compliqué ce que très très étrange c'est
que les artistes dont on parlait pour
prendre en sillac l'a vu qu'il est dans
l'actualité c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais une galerie qui a toujours été
contre qui était quelqu'un dont on n'a
eu aucune rétrospective dans un musée
important
enfin il ya eu une aux sables d'olonne
mais on veut dire c'est pas le centre
pompidou ou quoi que ce soit c'est à
dire que c'était des personnages qui
existait de manière un peu indépendante
or maintenant un jeune artiste qui sort
des beaux-arts il appelle tout la poésie
de la même position il ya le nouveau
deal de iaross donc s'intitule appelé je
vous remercie tous les trois doit
participer à cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]